the federal government is set to shut
down Friday of this week unless Congress
can pass a spending bill Republicans in
Congress seem like they're about to do
that they say they are so what's in the
deal well probably not a lot of what you
voted for in 2016 the final bill is
expected to spend 1.3 trillion dollars
that will of course dramatically
increase the deficit what it won't do is
provide a single dollar for the border
wall even though the president got
elected as you may remember on a pledge
to build one the law will not pull
funding from sanctuary cities even
though those cities are deliberately
acting to sabotage federal law on the
other hand the spending bill would
continue to give hundreds of millions of
tax dollars to abortion promoter and
Democratic Party's stal work Planned
Parenthood whose director spoke at the
Democratic convention publican party of
course promised to defund Planned
Parenthood not so long ago meanwhile the
priorities of this Congress seem to be
set by the Democratic Party rather than
by the parties supposedly in charge
Democrats have defined the terms of the
immigration debate from day one and
still are now they're doing the same on
gun control so how should Republican
voters feel about all of this Britain
was watching a lot of Congress's come
and go that's why he's our senior
political analyst at Fox and he joins us
now Brit is there a concern that
Republican voters will look at this and
be disappointed or will they be so
afraid of Democrats that they'll be
motivated to vote anyway I'm not sure
that's quite the choice I'm sure
Republican voters will be disappointed
with this but this is a very familiar
pattern we're seeing here and it comes
down to this it's a question of narrow
majorities in the United States Senate
today the Republican Party has the
narrowest of majorities and on most
legislative measures it takes 60 votes
that means you need Democrats and
Democrats when it comes to a big measure
like this are going to stand by their
sacred cows they're gonna stand by
Planned Parenthood they're going to try
their best to get the daca measure
renewed they're not going to get that by
the way in this bill but the president's
not going to get his border wall funding
either so there you go this is what
happens with narrow majorities if the
Republicans had healthy majorities in
both houses they would be able to pass a
bill that would contain all the
priorities you
and others as well and the Democrats
couldn't do a darn thing about it under
these circumstances however they can't
do that it's just they don't have the
votes right no it's when they try to
it's clear they can't I just wonder
though going into it if maybe there
wasn't over promising if people's
expectations aren't met it's just you
know someone promises you a pony for
Christmas and you get a bag of hair you
never get over it and so why would they
promise things that they couldn't
deliver well it wasn't well of course in
the course of an election campaign you
don't know how the election is going to
turn out you don't really you're gonna
end up with a small majority or a large
majority or no majority at all so you
come out and you say this is what I'm
for this is what I'm gonna be trying to
do now of course you always that always
gets translated to this is this is what
I will do believe me Tucker they're
democratic representatives and Senators
all over this country who went out and
promised all kinds of things that
they're not going to get either that's
how it is when it's when government is
divided like this very narrowly and it
and it's not a pretty sight I mean you
don't you used to be back in the day and
it's been a long time actually since
I've actually seen it worked this way
when there'd be a series of funding
bills that would be debated and voted on
and then they'd go then the two houses
would get together and they try to
resolve the differences and there was a
lot of bipartisan sentiment and
everybody would give a little to get a
little and you'd get that but in this
bitterly divided political atmosphere
the Congress is a reflection of the
country we have a very very deeply
divided nation and the kind of gridlock
you're seeing that leads to this kind of
extravaganza 1.3 trillion dollars is a
result of that no it's right a lot of
people don't believe in the system too
so really quickly you said that
Democrats stand by their sacred cows the
things on which they will not move
what are those for Republicans what are
the things they won't compromise on well
here's one thing the Republicans are
certainly going to get in this bill is a
significant increase in defense spending
which they've wanted for a long time
they had to swallow some they've had to
swallow some increases the domestic
spending they might not have wanted but
they're going to get that and obviously
you know they got there they got their
tax bill passed and this bill will leave
that undisturbed they're not going to be
able the and and as of now of course
Tucker one of the one of the great
priorities that is a that has defined
the Republican Party going back a number
of cycles has been the desire
to get into the entitlement spending and
and reduce that because that is the big
driver of these staggering deficits in
this massive national national debt that
we now face but we have a president now
who's not for that and without that
obviously you have no minimum no
momentum behind that so by the wayside
but look there's a there there are
plenty of Republican priorities in this
bill no doubt about it but I mean I
can't enumerate them all but there's a
lot of them there are any look anything
this big they're bound to be and of
course remember this about this bill
Tucker this is subject to the same thing
big Bill's always are big bills that
have to pass that is to say a bill that
would keep the government open people
are gonna try to attach whatever they've
got to that bill to try to get because
they know it's gonna get paid on that
law right and and and and so you get all
kinds of other look at ornaments hanging
onto these things most of them get
stripped out but some of them get
through and and when this bill is passed
we're gonna find out more over a period
of time but what's in it and a lot of it
nobody's gonna like some ugly ornaments
well well we'll tell you what they are
Brett thank you for that yeah okay
Tucker